Now it's also a matter of making it clear together once again that we support
Israel in defending its own country against the fruitful attack of Hamas.
That was 1.
Fertile,
brutal attack on children,
families,
young people and the elderly,
violating all the principles of humanity.
And that is why it is important that we take a clear stand.
I am convinced that this will be the case Just as we will work to
ensure that the hostages are now all released,
we will work for humanitarian support for the citizens of Gaza,
who are also victims of Hamas,
who have taken over power there in a coup d'état and are also using
their own population for their own purposes.